why are you gonna make me throw my mug
at you
i
why would you
get mdr to its numbers okay
hey guys pete here today i'll be talking
about severance episode three it's got
egg drop challenges speculation about
muscle shows and a trip to the
perpetuity wing which according to the
map is near the coil of doom i'm 99 sure
there was no coup but couldn't be sure
about anything else that's happening in
the basement of lumen industries just a
quick warning that there will be
spoilers if you haven't watched episode
3 in perpetuity yet and with that out of
the way let's get into it episode 3
starts right where the last episode
ended petey is struggling with the
effects of reintegration sickness his
memories of the office keep creeping
into his experience of reality in mark's
basement over pizza he tries to explain
what that's like it's like having two
lives stitched together which causes
problems but says that they said that
it'll get better mark wants to know who
they are and questions if it's the whole
mind collective he had an encounter with
in the last episode he says no it was
someone else but doesn't provide any
details when mark tells him that he
won't integrate because the process is
helping him petey asks what if the cost
of that help is that you're murdering
people eight hours a day and you don't
even know it he also tells him he
discovered a department that they don't
tell them about where the people never
get to leave the office but before he
can elaborate on that he glitches out
again and starts to talk about his
daughter next door mrs selvik's kitchen
is kind of a mess she made those cookies
the night before last and hasn't gotten
around to cleaning up apparently she
spent some of her down time watching
mark's apartment through her window and
you wouldn't know it from how they
interact inside the office but it does
seem that she has some concern for his
well-being that goes beyond just spying
on him for lumen there's a needlepoint
hanging on her wall that says we must be
cut to heal and that and other details
like how she drives a white rabbit are
really working for me mark settles in to
watch some tv and catches a debate about
severed employees the company line is
that severance is a choice that
employees should be allowed to make and
we'll see this new character natalie who
is very good at arguing in favor of it
later in the episode the next morning we
get reminded about how messed up it
actually is mark says that he won't be
reintegrating because it helps him deal
with his wife's death and in response to
this petey reveals that mark used to
come into the office with red eyes so
often that they had a joke about him
having an elevator allergy he was crying
in his car in the first episode and that
almost makes it seem like it's part of
his pre-work routine he's climbing the
corporate ladder though and on his first
day of reading the announcements rather
than interrupting them with his gas
habbing he has to break it to hely that
her audi denied her resignation request
back at his place rickens stops by to
drop off his new book which is
intercepted by harmony then she sneaks
into the house petey does hear her come
in so he's able to hide initially but
when she gets a call he starts to freak
out and leaves before she goes she gets
into the box that's filled with his
wife's crafts and takes the candle we
saw him look at whenever he was in there
before also petey starts looking at the
map and that leads him to wander away
from the safety of mark's house back at
the office heli is still trying to get a
message to her audi and she comes up
with what seemed to be fairly ingenious
ideas breaking the writing up on both of
her arms and swallowing the note inside
a makeshift capsule what really stands
out here is that mark not only picks up
on what she's doing but instantly has a
negative consequence at the ready in his
effort to talk her out of it where we
are it's a little hard to wrap your head
around how the code detector might
actually do the things they say it does
but what does it mean that these methods
have already been attempted the mention
of bad soap and milk check having to
know what end to try to extract the
capsule from hint that most people try
to resist being severed in the same ways
it's possible he's just making things up
to scare her but i find these little
details to be some of the most
fascinating things that we learned in
this episode
irv believes what heli needs is a deeper
meaning and suggests they go to the
perpetuity wing on the way there they
run into optics and design for one of
the funniest scenes of the series so far
really this whole trip out of the office
was super entertaining the tribal nature
of the groups dylan's antagonism that
felicia gives right back the chemistry
between irv and burt it's all working
here i laughed out loud at pretty much
everything dylan said on this excursion
while they're out natalie from the tv
debate does come in to see harmony we
get another one of these awkward
encounters where the board silently
listens while they wait for the person
to go first she tries to bring up that
there may have been some signs of
reintegration before he left but they
quickly shut her down and then we also
get the idea that there is some concern
that the department might not make their
numbers the perpetuity wing is about as
spooky as you would imagine but is also
somewhat believable at the same time
you've got wax figures of all eight ceos
from the 150 year plus history and a
complete replica of the founder kier
egan's home as much as herb is
enthralled by the history of it all it
doesn't work for heli and she uses the
opportunity to make another escape
attempt this time when she runs into a
locked door she smashes out the window
with a fire extinguisher that sets off
alarms and what i think she's trying to
do here is get her head past the sensor
so her audi will see the note in real
time mark pulls her back in though and
this time he has to let mr grayner take
her to the break room while she's there
we get to see how that works there's
some more interesting looking retro tech
a compunction statement they have to
read while they're monitored basically
taking responsibility and showing a
willingness to try to atone on the
surface it looks more annoying than
something you would actually fear it's
brutal in a way but it's not something
that seems completely scary so maybe we
still have more to learn about that as
mark is putting out the new group photos
he finds the map that pd left for him
it's on the back of the old photo and
you see mark leave it in the frame
before he leaves the office most of the
labels on it are for things they've
mentioned or things we've seen except
for that coil of doom i mentioned in the
beginning it's pretty fascinating and i
like the idea that he left it there and
that his innie will probably develop a
fascination with it when he gets home
audi mark realizes that petey isn't
there he's wandered into a convenience
store and was losing it asking for
tokens he's still bleeding from his nose
and all of that gets him a ride in an
ambulance mark arrives to see that go
down and he sees him fall to the ground
while the paramedics are bringing him
outside i don't think the implication is
that petey dies here going to the
hospital where lumen could find him
would be a worse situation at the same
time he did sort of do his part in the
story any mark has the map and audi mark
is starting to question the severance
procedure plus when he goes home to
clean things up he hears petey's cell
phone ring which means he will likely
have a connection to the people he was
working with while attempting to
reintegrate it's a great little
cliffhanger and the episode ends there
i feel like this was a nice shifting of
gears the first two episodes kept things
really uneasy and almost intense and i'm
not sure i would want that for nine
episodes straight i mentioned it in my
first video but i wanted to point it out
again how having us see that helly's
audi is all for taking the job makes her
any character so useful to kind of
understand how things work we see that
even when he's presented with evidence
that things might not be so great in the
basement mark still chooses to work
there as a severed employee there's
nothing to indicate that audi heli would
be any different the people who would
elect to have this procedure are so ripe
for exploitation from lumen everything
about it works in the corporation's
favor but there's also a subset of
employees who they could dupe into
thinking it's what they really want and
that desire makes them complicit they
become active participants which is a
bit more interesting than a story that's
just about a corporation screwing over
its workers
that all kind of ties into what i was
saying earlier about how mark doesn't
seem completely surprised about some of
these crazy ways she tries to get a
message out do they really have a bad
soap procedure because people try to
write notes on their skin have they
really had to pull notes out of people's
bodies and how would a code detector
even work i'm not sure but at this point
it isn't taking me out of it because it
feels like we're moving towards
something and that has me willing to
just sit back and enjoy the ride i think
the tv debate is something to remember
the idea that this is about choice i'm
not sure if the implication is that a
lot of other companies are already doing
this they've already adopted severance
departments but based on there being
protests and talk of legislation i'm
guessing that's going to be happening
soon it makes me wonder if it's not so
much about what they're doing in macro
data refinement but more about covering
up the inherent problems they would run
into while pioneering a procedure like
this if it's something that makes them
money and they could capitalize on that
further by it being adapted across the
country they would want to keep any
mishap secret when it wants to be funny
it's funny and i gotta say that i think
dylan is my favorite character which is
crazy when you think about what a
stacked cast this is zac cherry is doing
an outstanding job here where almost
everything he says is completely
memorable the inner office relationships
manage to hit that spot between this is
absurd and oh yeah this resembles every
office job i've ever worked irv
definitely goes to the bosses behind his
colleagues backs all the time this is
pointed out by the mention of waffle
parties and sticky notes in the
announcements and it's so funny that
there are only four of them so everyone
knows where this is coming from i like
that we got to see more from the
employees who aren't severed the whole
mug throwing incident was fantastic and
then that came full circle when she had
to have her meeting with the board i am
wondering why she took mark's wife's
candle and i guess they were reading
rickon's book to screen it before giving
it back to him i'm definitely looking
forward to seeing some more interactions
between the other departments whether
there are five of them or 30 and i think
i'll just leave it there let me know in
the comments what you thought about the
episode and what you're hoping to see
next week who's your favorite character
and what do you think is going on in the
basement of lumen industries please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon